foreign
's YouTube channel in the session we
will learn how to install MySQL in
Ubuntu but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you're a tech
geek in a continuous hunt the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply Now now without further Ado let's
get started with our one point agenda
that is how to install MySQL in Ubuntu
but before we begin if you are an
aspiring data analyst then I have the
perfect course for you we have the
professional certificate program in data
analytics bosche carrier over this data
analytics program in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IBM which features master classes
and follows an applied learning model
with real-time projects and business
case studies now that we have a clear
understanding of the GP data analytics
certification with simply learn in
collaboration with IBM from Purdue
University we will get started with our
tutorial for today's session so now
we're on the Ubuntu operating system
let's quickly start our terminal
the shortcut key for that is Ctrl alt D
so now we have the terminal opened so we
might have to run a few couple of
commands
so the first one would be pseudo apt
upgrade or update
that will ask for the host password
now you have the update
so usually what happens is when you try
with the default method or when you
drive the default codes or the commands
you might miss a couple of updates or
two or files right so what happens when
you try with the default codes the
default commands you might miss a file
or two so when you update the Ubuntu you
will get the missing files as well now
if in case if you find I've got all the
updates but in case if you find some
files are missing you might receive a
message from Ubuntu saying can't update
or not fetched right in that case you
can try upgrade command
even
then if you miss a couple of files there
is another similar command which says
sudo apt full upgrade we should also try
that as well
so basically what happens is you might
have one single command which says sudo
app install MySQL right so that
particular command will run but
unfortunately sometimes it messes to
face complete get and when it misses to
get all the files So to avoid that we
will try the brute force method which
will get all the files all the updates
on all the executable files you require
to run MySQL and Ubuntu right
just a couple of minutes yes
so similar to upgrade we have full
upgrade
it's done
and in case if you wanted to remove some
unnecessary files you have a command for
that as well so let's take a look at
that
so the sudo app Auto remove will remove
any of those old packages which you no
longer need after the complete for
Library let's run that
there you go so now we are done with the
Ubuntu update let's clear all the screen
by pressing Ctrl plus C shortcut with me
the shortcut key control L has been
press and the screen has been cleared
now now we are good to go with our SQL
installation command which is sudo
APD
get installed
my SQL
yeah so again we Face some issues
regarding the installation so this means
that we might have some files which we
might not need related to mySQL so my
suggestion would be to eliminate those
particular files using the sudo apt get
remove Purge MySQL server MySQL client
MySQL common yes
that is why so we're trying to remove
any of the existing files so let's again
let's try to get Auto remove
and auto clean
again the update
there you go we have the update and now
we shall try to install the MySQL server
with the following command but the
difference is we are trying to install
it with yes that is hyphen y
providing the permissions
there you go you can see MySQL is
running as pid6045
anyways let's also check the status once
the update is done
there you go let's quickly check the
status by using pseudo system control
status MySQL
and there you go
it says the server is operational and
the main PID is
6240 let's quickly clear the screen
using Ctrl L key combination and now
let's start SQL by using the command
sudo MySQL they should start my sequel
for you there you go that's how you
install MySQL and Ubuntu operating
system again you can run all your
queries based on my SQL and in case if
you want to quit just type in quit and
with that we have component of this
session and if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we use that has all the
codes that we use to clean the operating
system update the operating system clean
the existing MySQL files update the
system again and install the MySQL in
Ubuntu every single code has been
documented and if you need it let us
know in the comment section below and we
will have it shared with you at the
earliest and until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign